le foie gras physique on se retrouve dès
le 5 6 et 7 novembre au théâtre de saint
quentin pour le spectacle rejouer qui
est un spectacle alors il ya deux
comptes avec la même musique que pour
jouer qui raconte à la fois un compte
dans une première partie et puis les
réminiscences de votre enfant sain
est-ce que c'est laid c'est symbolique
ça du travail dans le compositeur c'est
à dire qu on est évidemment inspiré par
par des maîtres ou par des influences on
essaie de trouver sa place là dedans et
le contre-pied en est une le contre-pied
endettés nous aimer et justement c'est
assez intéressant de penser que en
essayant d'imiter quelque chose vous
faites quelque chose de très différent
wydad enfants mon obsession c'était le
contre-pied adultes mon obsession celle
inverse le pied c'est
d'aller chercher le parce qu'on n'a pas
confiance aussi maintenant j'ai
confiance profondément à la subjectivité
même si je joue ça j'ai confiance dans
la subjectivité que j'en ai alors que à
l'époque enfant j'avais qu'une seule
envie c'est et qu'on dise que c'était
moi mais j'aurais même volontiers à
enlever tous les exemplaires de l'a51 de
mal à
dire non mais c'était c'était
une des choses dans le domaine de la
deux l'emprunt parce que c'est une chose
à laquelle je tiens beaucoup avec le
travail que j'ai fait ici à saint
quentin et aussi avec peter brook et est
aussi allée christian boltanski est ce
que c'est vraiment je les associe comme
est d'aider des maisons dont il faut il
faut dire que vous avez travaillez
beaucoup avec twitter beaucoup le
théâtre avec question boltanski dans
l'est dans les arts contemporains
oui c'est ça c'est à dire que j'ai quand
même travailler toujours avec des gens
qui m'ont validé à l'intérieur de moi
l'idée qu' on était quand même constitué
d'un historiquement de deux composés de
composites de couches successives de
choses qui fait que et pour un homme de
théâtre c'est pas possible de raisonner
autres membres on peut par un moment
dire ceci non ceci oui non on l amalgame
de tout ça ce qui fait que je peux
mettre malheur est aussi fréhel oui
parce que et l'accordéon le piano la
gauche ps qu'on veut les pour moi c'est
très difficile de dire ceci est de moi
intégralement et et cendre le produit
quelque chose oui on est le produit d'un
film
de christian boltanski c'est
c'est même la mémoire en action on a le
sentiment qu'on peut même pas mettre la
main sur sept sur ce composite en
question donc voilà ça j'avais vraiment
ce souci dans ce conte savall très loin
ça va même quelque part dans des
acceptations de niveau entre la neuvième
de beethoven et les jeux vidéo dans ma
musique
oui mais complètement c'est à dire que n
importe quel moment
je peux avoir besoin d'une
toute chose qui a existé mais
vous parlez d'embellissement
à sa place dans
dans le mot beauté à partir de demain
elle est rentrée dans l'émotionnel dans
la subjectivité elle fait partie de
quelque chose que moi je ne peux pas
refuser au nom de quoi que ce soit ni
moral ni elles existent par exemple à
pour les jeux vidéo je me retrouve avec
à placer des mots qu'ils sont
taxe spéciale
c'est pas fait pour mais comme beau
finish c'est des mots qui existe
réellement pour
même pour cette musique là c'est à dire
quand je sais
je peux pas mesuré que ça que quelque
chose qui est en même temps bruce buck
taratata mais
là le mot qui avance ces bonus parce que
vraiment dès que vous avez une musique
de bruit
et puis ça repart dans le jeu et c'est
game over
game over jusqu'à la fin d'ailleurs qui
est assez joli parce que bon
je peux pas ignorer que ça à voir avec
les jeux vidéo ça
on
c'est votre try again c'est à dire que
quand j'arrête ici
imaginez qu'ils aient pas de pourquoi en
tant que musicien je fais ça
si je fais ça vous appelez ça une
cadence au jazz pour moi il est clair
que ça dépend uniquement d'un réflexe
ici qui est
trahie again
enter your name
c'est forcément un réflexe visuel de ces
cadences ont un autre sens à non plus du
tout le même sens aujourd'hui avec le
véhicule que j'ai eus avec ce qu'on voit
autour de nous et c'est donc évidemment
pour moi ça m'intéresse de rentrer bon
c'est pas de dire 7e deux dominantes ou
je sais pas quoi non c'est vraiment de
rentrer dans quelque chose qui est
émotionnellement actuelle quant aux
coques la fameuse phrase n'y a pas de
grande et petite musique est bonne et la
mauvaise
dernier a cassé on est constitué de
grandes est mauvais de tous la grande
majorité de la mauvaise très bien joué
mais ce que je le fait de les
réinterpréter de les rejouer
désapproprier comme vous le faites ça
transforme pas au fond on va tout
musique est une musique quoi mais après
c'est aussi la façon dont on a peu après
été dont on réinterprète du sénat rend
tout simplement méconnaissable mais de
larges ou retourner jouer quand je la
rejoins moi pour moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que ça la rend méconnaissable
c'est à dire moi même la seule personne
dont je peux dire que je connais rien
c'est moi les autres peu à peu près d'en
faire une idée mais moi non et là je
passe je vois que je passe une heure
cinq 1h10 sur scène seul
avec tout ça et toute cette mémoire cet
encombrement
c'est fascinant parce que je je je me
retrouve vraiment pour la première fois
sur scène en compagnie de moi même ce
qui est catastrophiquement l'eau
c'est une heure avec soi même c'est très
longue
et surtout cette angoisse ou pas oui
c'est assez
stressante c'est pas c'est pas un bon
exercice va faut pas le faire trop
souvent noël mais disons parce qu'on
rentre dans l'inconnu en fait c'est si
on rentre dans l'idée que on fait ça
pour
affirmer ce qu'on voudrait être c'est
pas terrible c'est fini d'abord ils vont
tout mon savoir ils ont tôt fait d non
moi je suis qu'un un immense point
d'interrogation sur moi même et il faut
nous chercher un peu alors par exemple
point d'interrogation les plus sur cette
musique là un moment ils sont donc dans
ce type d'exaltation de jeu et mener un
moment qui pour moi est vraiment dans le
conte complètement crucial
donc on a
donc intérieur name mais alors les
enfants sont la face c'est un enfant qui
les fait jouer à des jeux qu'ils
connaissent à des jeux extraordinaires
tout ça donc les deux autres enfants qui
sont en face de lui ils disent mais
comment tu t'appelles comment tu connais
tout ça et d'où viens-tu s'est fait une
espèce de 2,2 d'interrogatoire à l'heure
actuelle ces remous qu'il faut faire
mais disons qu'il ya un interrogatoire
poussé comme ça une urgence de vouloir
savoir tout cas du cap elle est pour
comment tu connais tout ça et c est là
l'enfant dix étrangers l'enfant
étrangers
l'enfant est rangé leur répondit avec un
air presque sérieux
je vais vous raconter mon histoire
donc il répond pas sur son nom il répond
pas sur ça il répond sur son histoire et
son histoire n'aura pas un mot
à l'instant ça serait logique que de la
musique et ça sera pire que tout pour
moi c'est un moment où
je suis pas je suis pas bien c'est que
je décide de jouer la chose qui le
souvenir le plus ancien de la musique
que j'ai entendu quand j'étais enfant
c'était un troisième moment la neuvième
de béton de mémoire
puisque vous aviez entendu break mais
mémoire libre d'accord c'est pas
forcément la partition pas du tout la
partition
je fais tous les raccourcis que je veux
c'est à dire c'est c'est le souvenir
souvenir et une vraie trahison un
rapport à l'origine importe
mais je leur dis voilà c'est ça et là je
pars dans un vraie inconnue hier par
exemple on a fait le filage
c'était furieux parce que tous les
autres endroits qui sont très difficiles
à maîtriser au niveau
on sait à peu près sorti cet endroit
suis là rien tous les errements
soulèverait le plus simple le plus
évident un coup de mémoire je savais pas
où j'étais je ne comprenais pas au jeu
je n'avais pas accès à cette porte là et
je sais pourquoi parce que je pense qu'à
ce moment là je ne réfléchis cette nuit
je me suis dit tu t'es mis comme idée
qu'il fallait que tu joues mais tom
bravo d'accord et donc là il y avait
forcément tout de moi parce que ben et
homme n'est pas alors que c'est de lui
oui mais il n'est pas le sujet n'étant
pas le sujet j'ai passé mon temps à me
demander où vous mettez cette partie
donc il faut que je décroche vraiment tu
joues pas bétonne tu joues le souvenir
de quelque chose il ya un accordéon dont
se passe la cellule pas ouais oui
c'est l'instrument par lequel vous avez
commencé mais voilà ça s'est il a mon
âge il n'a pas grandi enfin quoique mais
la mieux vieilli
il a mûri il un sont extraordinaires
donc ça s'éteint c'est un moment que là
pour ça c'est mon accordéon avec lequel
je jouais dans les bals poubelle ça oui
je n'ai pas fait beaucoup mais
quand j'étais enfant
on craignait beaucoup de me faire
dépasser certaines heures donc en fait
je me retrouvais ces gentilles quoi vous
voulez pas que je passe ma vie à être
sur scène dans la vienne bavaroise à la
fête des l'oeuf donc c'était vraiment
il fallait faire très peu donc du coup
je me retrouve est quand même
relativement sol est relativement
inoccupés
et dans ce cas là je confie t pour
sortir et c'est extraordinaire d'avoir
la possibilité dans une contre-allée
enfants et de voir le spectacle de la
fête le 100m dedans c'est génial donc
une grande partie là dans le conte
j'utilise salle enfants qui chante sur
scène
l'adulte le rejoint à un moment ça sort
de la taverne et se trouve nez à nez
devant lui et il le voit au pied d'un
arbre ou je ne sais quoi ils le voient
doit avoir en train de jouer de
l'accordéon mais d'une manière
complètement opposés à la fête donc il
ya un contrechamp que vous imaginez
vous avez ça est il rentré
tu vois c'est ça
profondément mois
merci infiniment franck la musique je
rappelle va rejouer donc 5 6 7 novembre
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
voilà j'espère que vous nous donnez
merci infiniment merci à vous